the most important election in America
is tomorrow get out and vote for Roy
Moore so I went down to Alabama last
week to see how the people were fighting
back against the liberal media's
despicable lies I read a poll that said
that 40% of the people of Alabama are
more likely to vote for Roy Moore after
allegations that he sexually molested
teen girls we're seeing more and more
supporters actually say they're now more
likely to vote for him because of the
allegations so I'm going to talk to
Republicans to see how they defeated
fake news yet again Road Trip baby but
Jordan wouldn't let me rent a Dodge
Charger so I did right out chrysler
pacifica i think it was just an attack
with way to eliminate somebody they knew
they couldn't beat even if it's true I
don't want to get above the Senate seat
right
these Alabamians weren't going to fall
for some bogus media narrative built off
of evidence facts and eyewitness
accounts but was there anything wrong or
could do to lose their vote murder
there's if I had been a victim I
certainly wouldn't vote for him so
that's nine people that probably aren't
voting for Roy Moore oh absolutely
if they came out and they said he's
shoplifting I wouldn't vote for it man
these are the people we want our kids to
look up to and I think they should live
to a higher standard
amen to that of course everybody knows
that shoplifting is the lowest form of
humanity are you more excited to vote
for Roy Moore after these allegations
came out yes it's like being a mom you
don't want to see your children bullied
you go after the bully he's older than a
child right and he's being accused
they're going after children but that's
right
exactly the real victim is Roy Moore how
can anyone survive under these attacks
he was going to have to live with this
for the rest of his life
ah one more loves kids
sadly some young people in Alabama have
been abused and taken advantage of by
the mainstream media do you believe the
allegations against Roy Moore I
certainly do
you believe those women yes he denied
the allegations and there's the
witnesses at the mall there's you know
the witnesses of the employees there was
that security guard who did say that had
happened you have the victims themselves
I just disregard all of that on his word
yeah it's he said they said nothing
riles me up more than thinking about the
fake news media they'd love to use facts
and evidence against people and I hate
it why can't they go to Canada go to
Canada go into the ocean drown
yourselves anyway it's fun to be an
Alabama roll tide the only way to fight
the MSM lies is to hear the unfiltered
truth straight from the horse's mouth
the horse in this analogy is human
stallion Steve Bannon and Just My Luck
he was speaking at a Roy Moore rally
fake news fake news your fake news dude
everybody's fake news your fake news oh
whoa sorry that's less Fox they're good
here I'm at the rally look at all this
excitement they are here to support
their man to defeat the liberal media to
defeat the fake news bias and narrative
that's been shut down the people of
Alabama come on we're not going by what
the liberal news says I could get with
them less about what they say shame on
them shame shame shame it's just an
attack it's just dirty politics
the allegations are kind of ridiculous
for it was 40 years ago so what if he
dated teenagers updated teenagers when I
was 30 exactly what when he was 30 but
they were 14 exactly whatever the
numbers were they were adding up for me
I thought you were Eric true I mean it
felt great to have everybody agree with
me and not challenge my support of an
alleged child predator I think common
sense tells you there's nothing to this
exactly common sense tells you one man
denied it nine women said it happened
but he denied it so yeah Oh Roy Moore
judge Roy Moore has more honor and
integrity in that pinky finger than your
entire family
got no more
that's the man with all the elevations
right there look at Roy Moore on stage
he's not touching anybody where's that
story CNN they think people in Alabama
are stupid that they're gonna bring this
up a month before the election and we're
gonna fall for it no you hear that
liberal media people are more excited to
vote for an alleged predator right now
they're not less excited
[Applause]
[Music]